Hello Freak bitches.
Here's Hillary.
Hillary turned brown.
Yeah.
Flat earthers um,
forests aren't real.
Is that what they're saying?
Jamie?
The flat earthers we're gonna talk about the flat earthers for one reason.
Um,
the reason why I wanted to bring this up is because I think there's a lot of
folks out there that are super gullible and I think they're being trolled.
I think they're being trolled by people who put together these,
it's one of two options.
Either they're being trolled by people who put together these elaborate
arguments for something that they don't believe because they're just trying to
make money off of youtube views,
which is entirely possible.
And this needs to be thought of.
I mean really needs to be considered because Lou youtube videos can be extremely
lucrative if you can get a youtube video with millions of hits and a lot of
these videos on all sorts of different conspiracies and all sorts of different
crazy things can generate that kind of volume.
You're making real money,
pennies on the dollar.
But if it's millions,
yes,
Yup.
It starts becoming real money.
It starts in,
if you do a bunch of them and you can,
you do them on a regular basis,
it becomes a Gig.
It becomes like what they do.
They create these silly videos,
but people who just don't have the time or the inclination to actually read
scientific papers and articles and journals and all these different things that
explain how we've known for a long time.
The earth is round,
right?
Yeah.
It's a myth that a Columbus proved that the earth is not flat,
that it's round.
They,
the ancients knew,
the Greeks knew.
Columbus knew.
Everyone knew a little bit then that it was round and Koreans knew absolutely
depictions on clay,
right?
Drew it in clay.
They drew all the planets as circles.
Right?
They knew,
right.
I mean there's some obvious simple ones anybody could do.
If you see an eclipse,
like a lunar eclipse,
you can see the Earth's shadow on the moon.
It's round.
Uh,
you know,
if you,
if you're high enough and you know,
the ships are sailing out,
you can see the mass does.
The last thing you would see as the whole drops over the horizon for slowly.
You know,
there's things like that that we know the earth is round,
you know,
you traveled around,
you come back to where you started.
Um,
you know,
now their explanation,
the flat earthers is that,
yeah,
it's round like a pizza,
but around flat pizza and all the continents are on the one flat face side up
and that the satellites are up there going around.
It's like,
yeah,
but the satellite photos don't show all the continents in one picture because
some of them are on the other side of the globe.
So that refutes that.
Well not only that,
but they think that satellites are actually in planes.
They're in planes and roll Orthopro over that or just circling around.
There's no actual satellites.
They don't even believe in saddle satellites.
Yeah.
So back to your original comment,
I,
some of these recent ones are so crazy that you can't help but think,
okay.
They don't believe that they're just yanking our chain for maybe financial
reasons.
But that does get to the question I always get,
which is do these people really believe it?
The cult leaders,
the,
that make a extraordinary claims,
are they just making this stuff up?
You know,
people make shit up all the time.
It's called fiction fantasy.
Uh,
or do they really believe it or they,
you know,
true believers and you know,
it's hard to tell.
It's hard to get inside people's heads.
Uh,
the old flat earthers in the 19th century,
I think they really did believe it.
Uh,
there wasn't much money to be made,
you know,
on those kinds of things.
I mentioned the Alfred Russell Wallace who was the co-discoverer of natural
selection with Darwin.
I wrote my dissertation on him and wrote a biography of him and he was quite the
colorful character who is so open minded to new ideas that he was also gullible.
So open minded enough to see this radical new theory of the evolution of life by
natural selection that's good.
Pioneered other fields like biogeography and so on.
But he also was really into spiritualism and phrenology,
seances handling all that stuff.
And then he encountered an ad in one of the natural history magazines for this
500 pound bet.
If anybody could prove the earth is round.
So he devised a test and he went down to the Bedford canal,
which is a long,
straight,
like 10,
10 kilometers long.
You can see the whole distance and if you put these little sticks in the ground
with markers on them and you get a little telescope like,
uh,
um,
surveyors scope and you line it up,
you can see that it bends.
So at each point the stick is,
you know,
three meters above the ground at each point.
And uh,
but you can see that it's dropped down in the last one.
So it's been,
so he won the bet,
but he didn't get paid of course,
because these people are cranks.
And uh,
so we had to take him to court.
This ended up costing him about 15 years of his career,
you know,
just wasting time,
writing letters and getting court dates and suing this guy and you know,
whatever.
The try to win the bet.
Yeah,
just try to win the bet.
So,
and of course what happens,
you get caught up emotionally,
like,
I'm not going to let this bastard get away with this.
You know,
you should have just cut his losses and laugh.
But anyway,
and I found these letters that this guy wrote to the National Jager or the,
um,
uh,
the Royal Geographical Society about,
Alfred Russell Wallace.
You know,
you have one member of your society that should be,
you know,
he's a quack and a crank and,
and he wrote letters to the two Wallace's wife,
you know,
you better not sleep in your bed at night quietly because I'm coming to get you
guys.
And it's like,
you look like death threats.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
it,
you know,
you're,
it's always questionable deal with cranks because some of them are a little,
uh,
mentally deranged.
Sure.
And they can attach themselves to someone like Wallace or Darwin or anybody
else.
If you can somehow or another connect yourself to them and some sort of an
argument,
it's kind of legitimizes you,
at least in a way,
because that person's giving you attention.
The person is engaging you and it elevates your standing.
And then whenever two people are arguing,
a certain amount of people are going to choose sides.
There's,
they're just gonna.
Even if that,
what you're saying doesn't make any sense,
there's going to be a gang of people that go,
all right.
Like,
what are you saying?
And they're going to join in and people love,
they love to be on a team.
Okay.